she doesn't owe me anything
I don't owe and neither of us owe
anybody anything except like respect
Haley Bieber is talking all things
Selena Gomez which includes a pretty
strong message to the actresses fans you
don't have to like me but you don't have
to say anything either oh my goodness on
the call her daddy podcast the model
goes into detail with host Alex Cooper
about getting hate online because of her
husband Justin Bieber's ex and there are
people that
hate you for who your husband dated back
in his past a lot of the hate and the
perpetuation comes from like oh you
stole him
and I guess maybe that just comes from
like the fact that they wished that like
he had ended up with someone else and
that's fine like you can wish that all
you want but that's just not the case
and Haley she weighs no time shutting
that rumor down and explaining her truth
when him and I ever started like hooking
up or like anything of that sort
he was not ever in a relationship ever
at any point
I would never it's not my character
to
mess with someone's relationship I would
just never do that I was raised better
than that he's a good kid he's a good
part and uh I love him the chapter has
been closed between cell and Justin for
years but fans just can't seem to let it
go and for Hales she seemingly reached a
Breaking Point in April when she made an
emotional plea on Tick Tock enough time
is on by where it's valid to leave me
alone I beg of you truly
that's my only request
be miserable somewhere else
I was like half joking but I was being
half serious like it was supposed to be
something that was like light and funny
but I was also being serious because
I like woke up one day and I was like I
can't believe we're still doing this so
while Haley tries to calm the waters she
explains why she doesn't expect Selena
to do the same I will say is
that she has been in this industry much
longer than I have and maybe there's
something that she knows about like it
wouldn't fix anything the thing is too
is like I think that like all everyone
is just trying to like create separation
even though there's clearly like not
always separation
I have no expectation I would never
expect someone to do that for me Point
Blank Haley's got a message for the
Selena eaters the first thing I would
say is you're not obligated to like me
but
I believe that no matter what there can
always be mutual respect between people
and to me that means
just you don't have to say anything and
Haley wants Selena's fans to know
there's no bad blood between them have
you guys ever spoken yes and then like
recently no I don't guess not recently
But like after your marriage
yes
so that's why I'm like
it's all respect it's all love that's
also why I feel like well if everybody
on our side knows
what happened and we're good
and we could walk away from it with
Clarity and respect then like
right that's fine
[Music]